today's topic
my name is bruno and i became a black
person
[Music]
no no no no no
no no
oh my god come on man oh no this is
quality american television no one knew
that i was actually black when i had my
white makeup on for six weeks two
families my family with black famine got
together in a house in the valley in l.a
and we decided to swap races
would go into makeup and become the
opposite race
we became black
they became white then we moved in
together
[ __ ] i cannot do this
[ __ ]
a
typical white american family from santa
monica
i just wanted to really
poke into the issue of race
i never played this game before i don't
know how to play i was curious to see
how the world would react to me as a
black person many times i was shocked
i'm sorry you don't look black you look
like a white man who left a coal mine
okay
he does not look black no no that's
offensive you don't look black you look
dirty
this is all over the place he looks like
a [ __ ] tintin character yes yo
you know those guys who would like carry
them around and go ooga booga yeah he
looks like that
we are the sparks family we're just a
typical black family from atlanta
growing up in michigan as light-skinned
green eyes
i had to fight the darker skinned blacks
because i was too light and then i had
to fight the whites because i was too
dark so i had racism from both sides
being white felt different wow very
different
that's danger fail right there when he
where's the bull felt like my stroke
just got suddenly better
i don't know what to tell you mo and i
just changed my skin color i just felt
like wow my my stroke game is just so
much better
we did something no one else has ever
done
i don't like being made up and none of
us will be the same again she looks like
the type of white girl to become a
teacher and go to the hood
and be like i can save you guys how do
you guys feel about poetry
remember freedom riders yeah being a
former basketball player i always
thought how nice it would be but they
have to jump get off the ground leap and
slam dunk like these guys can
there's no doubt about it
uh black's disappeared you know
physically uh hands down
he was on the mark hey man mom i'm not
even mad at it oh my god
i'm not even mad at it
wow
you look like oh
look it's ready come on white girl come
on
oh my god that is so strange
oh my god bruno
it's nice i love black i mean visually
i can't do this i can't do this
i can't i can't do this
bro i can't do it
i can't do it
visually i i love black that is exactly
what every [ __ ] wants to hear as he
pulls out his penis
i love black i mean visually and somehow
heart wise there's a warmth
you're beautiful
thank you you're beautiful
it's just weird you're [ __ ] weird see
these off you know what it feels like
nothing is gonna come out you know what
it feels like i think i know what it
feels like it's all man it feels like
it feels like you're behind
like a see-through glass and someone's
just being like
wow
i like darkness
oh he looks warm can i touch him honey
you look like a really nice man
oh my god
she got jungle fever
got jungle fever and that's where she
realized that yeah she's like oh my god
you really look like a black man that's
hot
i wonder if your penis got bigger
this is a gcc
yeah this is definitely part of their
role play digging it yeah um yeah if you
guys have never heard of race play uh
they definitely are going to be into it
yeah guys just really beautiful
[Music]
that's just like i'm in love with this
woman
it's beautiful
[Laughter]
did she just
did she just run away from her again
because he's black she's you said scary
yeah she can't see that's scary
like like you know what your thing is no
matter what they say
they can't win they can't win no they
can't win but they're not helping
themselves they can't how do you see
your dad in blackface and be like
[Music]
beautiful amazing job you totally look
like a little black girl
she looks like she got a pop on
instagram in sweden that's what she look
like okay and she likes black culture
that's what she looks like we look like
twins
today was like the experimental day it
was
the
yay or nay will this work
[Music]
my first time as a black girl i went to
south central
going undercover in the black world is
amazing
people were talking to me like my sister
see lee was trying to holler what holla
means
and mind you that was all before
internet and before you know what i mean
so people were not mingling so much so
there was a lot of lingo that they were
not aware of when i'm in black makeup i
wasn't like scared if anything i was
like i look black
people regarded me as a black girl
it was selling
that smells good
this guy should be pretty comfortable
right from the start
i'm really black whoa
i'm not talking about black man's shoe
whoa
there buddy
i have never in my life had someone you
know they come out and give me my shoe
but i've never had anyone actually
unlace it open it shoehorn the back and
slide my foot into the shoe is this what
the white guys get this is all the
benefits they get
the
guys every day everywhere at home like
i've never had anyone put a shoe with me
what if black guys ever were like
you and d grills don't
wow it's rather disgusting that you have
to live amongst the riff raff and ought
to have your shoes be placed onto your
deadlift kit soft feet
oh
how terrible it must be to be a negroid
i believe there's uh a lot that you can
take away from this experience
if you just place enough value and time
into
engaging with coccusoid ideas there may
be an opportunity for you to elevate
your position
oh it's never happened to me black in 40
years
the first time i go and buy shoes is
white
i have it done i was like wow the
possibilities are endless did it not
occur to you that maybe because the tv's
there and the camera crews there that
may be showing you extra customer
service and it's not linked to race you
know i'm going to be on television i
might go above and beyond make sure your
burger looks nice make sure your shoe
fits well no it's got to be about race
my expectations of living with a white
family i i was just hoping going in that
they were nice um that they were clean
when i'm getting ready to cook but the
kitchen's clean and dishes renee seems
very strong-minded very clear about what
she thinks well when i first married
carmen i thought she's weird
oh yeah you know why she's weird i'm
gonna tell you why she's weird because
she's on an experiment yes she is oh
let's see how you guys do it okay that's
why she's weird it's that glass window
that i told you about where it's like
you're observing somebody yeah that's
why it's weird it's like i'm trying to
talk to you and you're trying to gather
information as well you you trying to
just do your thing you just oh is that
where you poop you're just trying to do
you just try to do your thing but she's
really exploring oh is that how you guys
do it you guys eat the chicken bone
yeah interesting what is that thing
washing their chicken really oh they
washed their chicken
nick is very introspective he was uh the
quiet one of the bunch
he's getting into school shooters he
said i'm gonna be white let me do it
right
[Laughter]
one of my classmates calls me a tool
best believe i'm gonna shoot up to
school
bruno
buyers that's a pretty good one it's
pretty yeah first thing we had to do was
teach each other how to pass as the
members of the other race we're going to
help each other walk the walk and talk
to todd
all right so we got to help you out
okay yeah i was figuring i would walk in
and just basically high-five everybody
how is this a real shock
how is this a real show i see sola
stanley
being black
is a very subtle thing
i'm in this project to see if black
people are
just the same as white people by
becoming a black girl i want to see if i
can identify with other black kids and
learn about their culture today i went
to the mall and i met duran and poetry
who are in charge of a slam poetry class
they knew that i was white but i was
still in black makeup do you know
anything about that fortune 10
no
this is a setup there's no way this
cannot dwell there's no way this can end
well no
there's no way this can end well no
this is a setup and you see it's one
point something right
the resurgence of blackface when we say
what when we think oh [ __ ] he had bad
face back then
back then
people
were not so
i'm not saying that blackface is a new
thing
but
it's a resurgence of
people digging books and stuff like that
and they educate themselves because they
don't seem to be bothered i wanted to
see this
this today take place it wouldn't end
well just that
i agree never tried to do slam poetry
i want everybody to introduce themselves
and tell me your favorite entertainer my
name is latoya hicks my favorite artist
is marion blind my name is sheree busby
and my favorite entertainer is prince
okay blessed i'm an avid michael jackson
fan my name is jonathan my favorite
performer is dave chappelle
my name is rose and my favorite
entertainer i kind of love the
cranberries so the crackers cranberries
diversity yeah exactly
yeah
thank you for that rendition no brown
whenever we do our pawns we have to
stand up
okay
i don't know how to face this i'm
standing in the mirror faceless my
mama's at my shoulder telling me to
escape this there's so many far before
me with more life stories of prison and
death i'll take a deep ass breath what
what what is this that torment if she
says wow they look really angry
i'm a loser can you be mad at her
why would you doubt what she's trying to
say when she's made it clear clear clear
what she's trying to relate she doesn't
understand the emotion that's flowing
within the ocean of your chest
brother you know you came with the best
energy today
built in within the black community
there's a sense of synergy today okay
what you gonna say
am i wrong though you're not okay
because right now i'm in the flow state
click clap
this is texas baby this is a gun stick
why are you laughing get off my property
you on my estate you got that essay
huh how about you look
you feel me that's pretty good that's
pretty good i'm not really mad at myself
no hey that's right let's go yeah yeah
yeah yeah
but you didn't clap though you didn't
you didn't you didn't
you didn't snap no you didn't snap for
abazu
do your thing
you can do it all by yourself
baby girl what's your name
i'm the pain
i felt like
a lamb
in a lion's den these people rock and
they're speaking about being black from
their heart of hearts and i'm hoping to
god that this sounds black
okay
thank you
many words my life the so simple
complexities of a human psyche to even
relish in my thoughts of romantic stride
my skin to his
my touch returned a mutual undulation of
want and reciprocal acceptability and
performance a ritual so profound the
taste of sex the body flushed with hot
and sticky fantastic a basket of
unbroken fruit a dripping bouquet of red
ripe woman the pulp of the soul spread
lavishly over the human chemistry when
discovery and pleasure were encouraged
thank you
the performability of the lavish ways
the which way fruits and red engages
with the blush colors of orange and blue
as an azura ocean comes in contact with
my proliferation of emotions
breeding within me a scene that i
haven't seen for a long time a strong
sign that what i'm feeling is love cove
and a hot warm dove
the title of this poem is baby you
trying to [ __ ]
that's what i felt like
were you nervous
shitless yes
i felt that you were nervous so yeah
just uh you have a lot of big words
have a lot of big words i don't get you
know and you have to know your audience
and know that if you're speaking
to an audience of people that not
everybody's going to understand what
you're talking about i'm not about to go
into a place and pretend that i know
what i'm doing
but if for some reason i start changing
and growing and learning in a different
way that i didn't expect i'll let it
happen
when i started to realize that it did
feel real and it made me feel like now
i've got some friends on board and that
i needed
how do white women dance
you know exactly it's very wavy isn't it
it's wavy yeah isn't that exactly what
she's doing because what they're trying
to do is that they're trying to catch
the music yeah they're trying to catch
the music
it's in there up there oh here's the
base
my dad is always talking about how white
is treated differently than black people
but my generation now we really don't
see all that we just see people as long
as you cool with us then we cool it too
oh my god wow amazing i'm gonna be white
today so i want to go and do something
only white kids do
today i'm going to etiquette class with
nick to see how well he blends in with
white kids nice to meet you claudia
maybe like really bougie rich white kids
from bel air white kids do not do this
claudia rose nice to meet you timothy
hi i'm claudia nice to meet you nick
etiquette actually it's not just rules
it's the way you behave the way you're
going to be accepted basically teachers
you know how to eat their fancy
restaurants and how to greet people and
be polite i want to see you pretend to
eat your soup pretend pretend you're
really eating contaminated
okay
you eat from the inside to
the outside yeah
remember when your mom used to feed you
it was like this
yes okay you guys are grown-ups now i
actually don't think nick is enjoying
himself at all
what do you think what do you think
about the first episode
it was it was like to be fair there were
some other scenes in regards to stuff
like um i don't know i didn't really
watch it completely but those scenes
about you know the guy goes to buy a car
for the first time as a black man so
there's a lot more honestly i didn't
think for us to watch the whole 40
minute episode we would have lasted
so i just had someone cut up highlights
for me yeah if you guys enjoyed this
we'll we'll do some more there's going
to be two other episodes on the patreon
and if people really want the series out
we'll put it out publicly but good lord
but you have to advise you have to have
to you have to warn me before what i
can't do this like do what this is hard
to watch it's hard to watch this what
was hard about it it just cringe there's
a lot of cringe more than skippy cringe
man listen back in the day they had some
crazy shows they were just like man what
can we make money off of anything we can
make money off let's do it
and they really did that [ __ ] but uh
shout out to them
but yeah you
asked me what i thought about that and
it's just that they have their
stereotypes like black people and white
people all wrong
like it's bougie bougie bougie
boozy [ __ ] you know and they just the
show it's not even the people on the
show that was inherently racist or
whatever
it's the show
the show was hey man
what they were proposing was just
the makeup was
trash neither of them really looked
white except for the sun and neither of
them really looked black period
they really look like they went into a
coal mine
worked for a full day and came out i
decided they weren't gonna shower
anymore well the least person the least
bad person was
the the white girl
that's the makeup that was the least
crunched but no it was terrible two
parents that's terrible god damn but
anyways what do you guys think in the
comments we want to hear from you guys
what did
horrid